when is the central bank not a central
bank when is a private bank public and a
public bank private sound mysterious and
full of secrets well that's the Vatican
Bank a new book called God's bankers
reveals the history and operations of
the catholic church's own bank here's
the author Gerald Posner this is an
institution of men who believe that they
represent Christ on earth that the one
true religion and for nearly two
thousand years eighteen hundred of those
years they didn't like the idea of
capitalism they were Pope kings they had
the papal States fifteen thousand square
miles of Italy so they levy taxes that
paid for this enormous royal court and
lavish court once they lost their empire
the earthly Empire became the Federal
postage stamp piece of land the Vatican
City they said how do we get money so
they got it from donations to the Pope
Peter's pence they were they were sold
indulgences pieces of paper that told
the faithful you're forgiven for your
sins if you contribute that didn't raise
enough money they were still looking for
ways to raise money and what finally did
it is in 1929 they hit a deal with
Mussolini the head of the fascist state
he recognized them as a real country
that little piece of land and in return
gave them about a billion dollars in
today's money compensating them for the
loss of the papal States they said what
do we do with a billion dollars we're
clerics not finance ears they hired a
guy who was a brilliant financial whiz
Bernardin and agarró he came in he
understood arbitration understood
offshore banking understood how to move
hard assets around investments in real
estate and he started to do that in the
middle of World War two he said the Pope
I need a bank it's not enough to have
correspondent banks we needed to move
our money off the radar so the British
and Americans can't follow what we're
doing because they were playing both
sides the Americans in Bert's they were
investing in and the Germans and
Italians they didn't know who would win
they wanted to make sure they were
covered and that's the birth of the
Vatican Bank they go from an institution
that can't embrace capitalism to one
that suddenly has its own bank in the
middle of the war in his charter in
which it was founded in 1942 there's one
shareholder it's the Pope there's no
directive that it should turn a profit
it does turn a profit we believe often
but it's hard to tell there's a rule
that every ten years it will destroy its
files most banks don't do the
they were doing that until 2002 in
addition everything that's run is in the
dark there's no transparency at all it's
sort of secret so in essence they've
created they meaning the Vatican had
created an offshore bank in the center
of the Vatican in the center of Rome and
for Italians who had money this was very
enticing because here's Vatican City and
there's Rome right around it there's no
wall between the two and it meant that
if you were standing in Rome and you had
a million dollars in cash and you didn't
want Italian authorities to know about
it or you were mobsters and didn't want
prosecutors chasing it you just had to
find a priest who was a friend or the
family to deposit it into a Vatican bank
account and the minute it went in there
it disappeared and nobody could find it
that meant it was tough for me as a
researcher so I asked for access to the
Vatican Bank files and they sort of
smiled and said no I asked for access to
the secret archives where the Holocaust
era files are still buried and they gave
a much nicer of a longer process before
they said no they ignored requests for
interviews so pretty much they kept me
at a distance no cooperation I wasn't
surprised as somewhat disappointed but
it forced me then to go out to the
archives at different countries from
Romania to Russia to England to the US
and sort of pieced the story together
from those old files the Holocaust and
Nazi Germany and communism in 1933 the
Vatican does a Concorde out a deal with
Nazi Germany to acknowledge the Third
Reich to sign a deal with the Third
Reich a treaty and that was a big thing
for Hitler he loved that and in return
he had them signed meaning the priests
and the bishops have signed oil tea oath
to the Third Reich the Vatican collected
a tax for years eight to ten percent of
Catholics in Germany of their of their
payroll went to the church Hitler agreed
to collect it at the source as sort of
straight as a payroll tax from the
equivalent of taking it off the payroll
and give it to the church meant a big
increase it put the Vatican and Nazi
Germany like this you also had a pope at
that time would take it over in the 30s
who had been the papal nuncio to Germany
for the best years of his life his top
aides were all Germans he loved things
German when the war broke out the it
worked to Germany's benefit because the
Vatican Bank once it existed with a pope
who had known and liked things Germany
by Pope Pius the 12th when the initial
reports came in
about the civilian slaughter and they
came into the Catholic Church in the
Vatican before they came into the Allies
and the reason I say that with such a
firm conclusion is the Vatican have
something that the Allies didn't have
they had priests in all of the little
parishes in Poland which was ground zero
for the killing fields in Croatia in
Romania and Hungary those priests
reported what they saw on the ground
back to their bishops and those bishops
sent them in cables to the Secretary of
State's office in Vatican City the
Secretary of State's office met every
day with PI's the 12th they had those
early reports from 1940 and on about the
icing group and the mass killing squads
to mobile killing squads they stayed
remarkably silent during the war and one
of the things that's raised I talked
about it in this book is people have
posited theories over the time why
wasn't the Pope more active why didn't
he step in why didn't he use his moral
authority to say to Catholics who are
committing the atrocities were basically
Catholics in the Nazi Party some
Lutheran's as well this is a mortal sin
to kill Jews he will said it's
anti-semitism he was afraid that Hitler
would move against him or against
Catholics I also think that one of the
considerations was money there were
profits being made by the Vatican Bank
and others with the Germans and until
late in the war they did not want to
upset that